as john gant gets the call for the
cardinals
microscopic era for john gant 1.83
but don't think he hasn't had a lot of
traffic but the walk strikeout ratio is
not good that's something
he certainly needs to work on and adam
frazier will
lead things off the lefty hitter
that pitch is popped up arenado giving
chase but coming on to make the play
will be justin williams
brian reynolds
out to tommy edmond he'll make the catch
and one two three go the pirates
take a look at the numbers brought to
you by pennsylvania lottery
of jt brubacher excellent 258 era
that's outstanding in his control number
is very good
at nine with 41 strikeouts oh so it's a
rare walk
just the 10th and 39 innings
stinner brings in nolan oronato and
orionato is homered in three straight
coming into play
two outs runner at first arenado with a
drive
into left center at the wall
gone four games in a row
for nolan two-nothing cardinals
but boy can arenado go down to get it
love the head
through the baseball the long extended
swing so matt holiday like
always something going on
and that one finds the grass of the
outfield a hit for polanco
and tom now combined with pittsburgh and
the oakland athletics is hitting 170
as a pirate eight hits in 37 at bats for
216
average and a high fly ball out did deep
right field
carlson back he's near the wall he's got
it up against the wall
dylan carlson long way to go
and makes the catch up against the wall
[Applause]
that's first and second one out in the
pitcher john gant who's 0 for seven with
three strikeouts
again gets down the bunt and the only
play two first
and they almost threw it away frazier
had to leap high for that
shift on the right side tommy edmond and
a fly ball
into shallow left tom coming on may drop
and it does
two runs will score a little gloop in
the left two runners come in to score
and it's a four-nothing cardinal lead
off the bat
of tommy edmond to outsand
two on goldschmidt
to center again and twice he is lined
out to brian reynolds
cardinals strand a pair but they pick up
two in a bloop hit by tommy edmond 4-0
3-2 pitch to michael perez swung on and
missed
and the first strikeout tonight for john
gann
that's first and second for brian
reynolds brown comes alive a bit the 3-2
check swing and he got him as they
appeal down at third
and bill cosby wrung him up sosa
has yet to drive in a run at the big
league level he'll have a chance
trying to pick up arenado from second
molina from first the runners lead
a swing and a drive down the right field
line that ball is going to hit down
and bounce off the track off the wall
scoring arnado
molina stops at third and there's the
first big league rbi for emundo sosa
five nothing cardinals
ian has really been able to keep his
pitch going
low the 2-2 pitch
backed again
and brubaker said i've had enough and
back to the dugout he goes
so two outs in here is adam frazier
and there's a ground ball to paul
goldschmidt and one two three inning
choppy first three innings for brubacher
at least in the fourth and fifth he's
much more efficient
and to think about salvaging a night
where you give up five runs to give your
club six innings
and he's on his way to doing that
williams is struck out three times
against jt brubacher with his first one
two three in there
two three four in the order against
gantt
this was hit fair inside the third base
bag
for kevin newman and he will head to
second base
and take the turn at second and hold on
with a lead off double
so one walk through his five innings
trouble now here in the sixth
first two have reached in this is will
craig the 1-0 pitch
up the middle again knocks it down can
get the lead man and he does
wow self-preservation wow and turns it
into an
out watch this
trying to reach the glove up and didn't
get as much glove as he got hand
but had the presence of mine after
stopping it
to find it and get the lead runner man
they're gonna take
out and so the runners do move up on the
wild pitch
and now
[Applause]
reynolds is in give an rbi to polanco so
pirates on the board
here's eric gonzalez here's the one-two
pitch and a breaking ball and off the
glove of cabrera and that's gonna
deflect towards second gonzalez is gonna
reach first without a throw it's a base
hit it's an rbi
and it's a 5-2 game as craig scores this
batter perez dan
is four for 42 this year
and he had a three-hit game
he's over his last 21 and the 1-2
struck him out well geo made the pitch
and he got the call right in the upper
left quadrant of the strike zone perez
didn't like it
lined out to left field could be trouble
williams backhand makes the catch
adam frazier retired one for four on the
night and let's stretch it's 5-2
two on one out and the batter harrison
bader
this pitch is in the air shallow center
reynolds coming on and he makes the
sliding catch boy he's perfected that
feet first slide brian reynolds
it's justin williams who's glad to see
anybody but jt
brubacher having struck out each of his
first three at bats against the pirate
starter
there's a swing and a miss for the
strikeout as stratton
gets williams a frustrated left fielder
for the saint louis cardinals goes down
for a fourth straight time via the
strikeout
and the pirates down to their final out
shift on the right side and a one-two
pitch
fly ball pretty well hit but that'll
back up williams and he
is there the cardinals take game one of
the series
a final of five to two